vamos a tratar de calcular la suma de esto que tenemos aquí
evaluar esta expresión de esta suma y hay varias formas de realizarlo
una podría ser por ejemplo utilizando fuerza bruta digamos, tomamos n igual a 1
vemos cuanto vale esto de aquí cuando n es igual a 1, luego tomamos n igual a 2 y vamos sumando todos esos
y es un procedimiento, digamos legal o sea se vale, es correcto realizarlo de esta forma
pero creo que  es una buena oportunidad para ver propiedades de esta notación sigma
que hemos estado trabajando en los últimos vídeos, así que lo primero que quiero que veamos es que esto
yo estoy sumando tres cosas, muy bien, tengo la suma de tres n cuadrada mas dos n mas cuatro
y esto yo espero que sea facil de convencerte que es lo mismo que la suma desde n igual a 1
hasta 7 de tres n cuadrada mas la suma desde n igual a 1 hasta 7 de dos n
mas la suma desde n igual a 1 hasta 7 de la constante 4
y esto realmente es muy sencillo de ver porque en realidad la suma es asociativa y es comnutativa
podemos ir sumando estos términos y después arreglarlos para agruparlos de esta forma
yo de hecho te recomiendo que los desarrolles, desarrolles este lado derecho
desarrolles este lado izquierdo y agrupes de tal forma que puedas ver que al agruparlos estas dos cosas son exactamente iguales
y no es muy difícil de ver simplemente por las propiedades de la suma
Ahora bien. este ultimo termino, es muy fácil de calcular, piensa que cuando n vale 1 lo que estamos evaluando aquí dentro es 4
cuando n vale 2 lo de dentro vuelve a ser cuatro y asi sucesivamente, entonces lo que esta pasando es que estamos sumando 4 mas 4
y asi varios cuatros, siete veces, asi que todo esto de aqui son 7 veces 4 que son 28
Vamos a ver que pasa con esto, si nosotros tenemos n igual a 1 esto vale 2, cuando n vale dos esto de aqui vale 2*2 que es 4
cuando n es 3 esto vale 2*3 que es 6 y asi vamos sumando hasta que n vale 7 y 2*7 es 14
así que esto por ejemplo lo podemos ver como la suma de los primeros 7 multiplos de 2 o bien podemos factorizar un 2
factorizamos 2 y esto multiplica a 1 mas 2 mas 3 así sucesivamente hasta 7
entonces lo que estamos viendo con esto es que esta suma es lo mismo que el doble de la suma desde 1 hasta 7 de los primeros 7 enteros
muy bien, así que esto lo podemos ver como 2 veces la suma desde n igual a 1 hasta 7 de n
y esto por supuesto lo que me esta diciendo es que este 2 puede salir de la notación sigma, verdad?
lo estamos esencialmente factorizando, déjenme agrupar esto, después le vamos a sumar estos 28 que encontramos aca
y  lo que podemos hacer es exactamente lo mismo, con esta primera suma, esto sera 3 veces la suma
la suma desde n igual a 1 hasta 7 de n cuadrada, muy bien y esto va agrupado y lo sumamos con los otros dos terminos
que ya tenemos, entonces, la pregunta aqui ya es.... bueno, lo que pudimos hacer fue
factorizar estos números y sacarlos de la notación sigma, ahora la pregunta es como calculo
la suma de los primero 7 enteros o la suma de los primero 7 enteros elevados al cuadrado
y para esto hay formulas, para esto hay formulas, de hecho te las voy a proporcionar estas formulas
en este caso seria, 3  que multiplica a 7 al cubo entre 3 mas 7 al cuadrado entre 2 mas 7 entre 6
muy bien, este es la primera de estas formulas.. y ahora la formula que corresponde a la suma de los primeros
n enteros, aqui voy a poner el 2 que corresponde a este 2, que multiplica a... lo que puedes ver es como
si fuera  el primer termino mas el ultimo y luego pomediamos y luego esto lo multiplico por 7
y finalmente le sumamos 28, por supuesto estas formulas, lo que puedes hacer es buscar
en internet e incluso aqui mismo en la Khan-academy, asi que estas formulas ya te las estoy
proporcionando digamos, OK, entonces uno fácil de calcular es este de aquí por que tenemos
2 veces  este numero, pero aqui esta dividiendo entre 2 entonces tenemos 2*7 es 14
entre 2  es 7 por 1+7 que son 8, así que esto de aquí vale 7*8 que son 56, vamos a sumarle estos 28
que teníamos de este lado, y ahora vamos a ver que hacer con esta parte
lo que podemos hacer es por ejemplo multiplicar por 3 y entonces tendríamos 3*7 al cubo entre 3 es 7 al cubo
mas 3*7 al cuadrado entre 2, mas 7 entre 6*3, que seria 7 entre 2, muy bien, entonces
aquí podríamos multiplicar por 2 y dividir entre 2, y hay lo tienen, muy bien entonces tenemos que calcular
vamos a hacerlo, 7 al cubo es 343 por 2 esto nos da 686, y si... bueno vamos a dejarlo así,
686... entre 2 mas, tenemos 3*7 al cuadrado y 7 al cuadrado es 49, entre 2..., perdón, es 49*3, nos da 147
esto es 147 entre 2 mas 7 entre 2, entonces lo único que hay que hacer es sumar!.... y nos da 840
y todo lo estamos dividiendo entre 2,así que dividimos entre 2 y nos da 420
esto sera,esto de aquí es 420 y si sumamos ahora 420+56+28 esto nos da 504
el resultado final es 504, y ahora si nos merecemos un redoble de tambor porque ademas de todo
de que hay muchas formas de resolverlo, siempre es bueno saber como descomponer el
problema, ahora bien estas formulas de aqui yo te invito a buscarlas aqui mismos
en la Khan-academy debe haber vídeos de esto y deberías ver como se deducen
yo no soy fan de ver, de dar las formulas, sustituir y  simplemente ya, hay tienes el resultado
yo mejor te invito a que lo busques aquí en la Khan-academy y que veas de donde salen estas formulas
la serie aritmética y la suma de los primeros cuadrados